hi everyone my name is Jin Cal I am a
tech reporter at Bloomberg News in New
York joining me today is AJ Forsyth he
is the co-founder and CEO of I cracked
which helps to repair your iPhones and
iPads and today AJ has spent the entire
morning in line for this new iPhone 7
and we're going to take it apart and see
what's on the inside do you want to talk
really quickly about what you do yeah
absolutely thank you for having me so
I'm with a company called I cracked we
have 5000 mobile technicians around the
US and in a couple other countries we're
anywhere in the US whenever you break
your phone or your it can either be
Android or your iPhone you press a
button and we'll send someone to your
home or your office to repair it for you
and it's really cool cuz we're about
five years old and I never thought it
would get to have thousands of
technicians helping customers but it
seems to be a pretty fun fun time to be
in the industry
yeah and dude I mean right now we have
the iPhone 7 which you couldn't get the
plus right tell us about that what hello
absolutely so we we actually had a team
of people in line for seven days at the
5th Avenue Apple store and we met them
very early this morning and we bought a
bunch of iPhone 7s and we wanted to get
the 7 plus but they told us what the
Apple store told us late last night that
they didn't have any in stock at their
flagship Apple store which was crazy
right I think Apple had some issues with
getting a supply components for the dual
camera or something like that really
they limited the number of iPhone 7 plus
s that were sold and then late they were
limiting the supplies in the stores and
it was pre-orders were completely sold
out so I mean so showy it's crazy yeah
absolutely so we're gonna do an unboxing
and then I'm gonna see if I still have
the skills needed to take this apart and
and then I'll talk about like the
differences between this and the last
generation so we will sorry seven days
were you the first in line
we were actually seventh eighth and
ninth in line there was someone who had
been there since August 26 who was the
first in line Wow so before Apple even
announced the phone he was camping out
howdy I didn't see you there a couple
months ago you know I'm gonna wait it
out I'm not the kind of person who likes
to get there first in line but
absolutely so this what's cool is this
is one of the first iPhone 7s in at New
York City so we're gonna take it apart
here and I'll show you some of the
differences yes so this is the matte
black and one of the most notable
differences is there's no headphone jack
anymore yeah absolutely so this is these
are the ear pods and what's unique about
this is it comes with an adapter so you
can still use headphones wired but
that's going through your Lightning port
instead of the 3.5 millimeter jack and
then the adapter is for a 3.5 millimeter
jack yes if you have your old it's no
yeah I don't know if you have the
adapter it shouldn't change much and
then that what's most notable is the the
Lightning port is on the headphones now
so you're you're going off the off the
Lightning port instead of the audio jack
but so I'm going to put this aside and
we will turn this on that the air pods
and III would lose it so one of the
other unique things about this is the
first time you use it the home button
doesn't actually press in so you're used
to like pressing a physical home button
this one that they it's they have a
what's called taptic feedback where you
touch it and it vibrates the phone but
it's you're not actually like pushing a
button if you try it for like try it for
the first time and it's like amir it's
kind of a really weird I feel a click
but it feels like it's not the same kind
of click does this mean that the home
button is less likely to break because
in the older generations a lot of times
your home break so that's that's a great
question actually so we
we do tens of thousands of repairs a
month and we do quite a few home button
repairs so hopefully it's not going to
breaks it's that less moving parts the
better but so I'm going to power the
phone down and we will start doing start
taking apart about the iPhone 7 is that
it's now waterproof ip67 it's the
standard used and so what when you're
taking it apart what's different for
this phone versus the previous
iterations yeah so that's a that's a
great question so ip67 basically says
that you can submerge the phone in 3
feet of water for 30 minutes and what's
really unique is there's a gasket that
goes on the inside which makes it taking
this apart actually pretty difficult so
I'm gonna take out these bottom two
screws and I'll show you how that you
how you remove the screen and what that
gasket looks like it does take a couple
minutes to open so I want to be upfront
that it's it's somewhat delicate and
takes a few minutes but I'm going to
start by now that we've removed the
proprietary two pentalobe screws I'm
gonna start by trying to wedge up the
screen it opens as if it's a book so it
opens from left to right like like that
and and we should have had for a while
now is the process of waterproofing that
Apple used here similar to that process
that Samsung used yes so it's so Samsung
so we repair quite a few Samsung as well
they use gaskets as well as a
hydrophobic coating which raise
hydrophobic coatings our nano coatings
that prevent water from actually
touching the electronics imagine it like
imagine it like a layer of paint almost
but that it prevents water from touching
it
so Apple employed this gasket which
we're trying to get under which you can
somewhat kind of hear the gasket
separating I can kind of see there's a
little bit of
a little bit of a gap so I'm gonna try
to wedge this in there and we'll see if
that uh so you basically kinda have to
pop it yes and we actually should be
able to hear it if I don't sometimes you
can accidentally break the screen doing
this so we may have one of the first
broken phones in New York as well but so
you can helps that we are repair company
so I'm going around the edge and this is
a tool that we helped design to open it
but you should be able to hear here the
gasket separating so I think the if you
remember the age of like having a CD
drive in your laptop floppy disk I think
it's just it's floppy disks for our
younger viewers
we're amazing and so first of all it was
a three and a half millimeter deep hole
in the phone so it's it let in water and
dust and and then just Bluetooth
Bluetooth 4.0 it it's somewhat redundant
having a audio jack I think it's going
to bother a lot of people however that's
why you have your adapter but I think I
think in the future we're gonna look
back and realize it wasn't that big of a
deal how many people right now even own
I I personally don't own one I tried
using one once before and did not have a
great experience with it just pairing or
what sound quality I just didn't think
it was as good as the traditional 3.5
millimeter headphone jack I know the
spec technology is what decades old but
you know it's not it's not broken don't
fix it actually as a repair company I
agree with that so I think I listen I
think in a couple years we're gonna look
back and it's gonna look as if it what
like CDs look to us now so I know I
trust I trust the engineers at Apple to
have made it a great
experience so we're we're about to
separate the screen and I will show you
guys the inside of this so we're not
going to crack those we may so without
the headphone jack what does that leave
room for Apple to do so I'll actually
show you that that's a great question so
we we went over how the we went over how
the home button actually doesn't
physically click anymore and I'm gonna
go over the engine internally that helps
power that so you can see this is
starting to starting to separate so we
can see we can start seeing the backs
back to the LCD and then we're gonna
actually see the gasket that's internal
that keeps that dust and water out but
what happens if you put it back together
what happened what do you have to do so
we're actually working on a we're
patenting a jig system that allows you
to put the water proof seal back on it's
not we haven't released it yet but we
ideally want to get your phone back in
the shapes and it was when you first got
it so I at this point though I don't
think anyone can recertify ip67 after
after a repair even with samsung phones
because you're still used eat like a
tiny bit of debris in the gasket if it's
not them in a clean room could let in in
water and mess up your phone but so
we're gonna start prying it out and then
I will open it like this you pull down
so it is it is yeah it is adhesive and
check this out so you can see that now
that the device is opened we can we can
see a couple interesting things we have
two wires coming off yes so this is the
wire for the front-facing camera
proximity sensor an ear speaker so that
just give a run reference that is right
here so the I believe it's a eight
megapixel iSight front
camera and then the rear camera is 12
megapixels and you can see that it is a
lot larger than the previous generation
and then you have your four led true
tone flash but because this is not the
plus we don't have that cool dual camera
that's supposed to be not quite a DSLR
but it looks amazing I'm certainly gonna
probably enjoy taking photographs with
it but this is this is just a single
camera it's supposed to be much faster
and I mean apples amazing at at their
hardware so we're gonna keep looking in
here so right here you have another wire
that is for the LCD and touch digitizer
as well as home button and so we see
that Oso touched it basically if you
imagine a invisible grid on the screen
it it knows when and how hard you're
pressing yes so that that helps the that
well that that is the touch front
function it's on what's called a
digitizer and we can see the wires for
the LCD and digitizer coming off here
and then we have the battery which takes
up about 60% of the internal volume so
right here is where you're used to the
existing or the pre-existing headphone
jack that's no longer here and we can
see that Apple has fit in a what's
called a taptic engine and so if you if
you imagine a series of internal magnets
in this taptic engine that when you
press the home button it vibrates the
phone so the vibrations actually coming
from this tap to earlier when we were
pressing down on the home button and
feeling that sort of feedback that
wasn't quite the click that's what's
doing yes why is that better it's it's
definitely a it's definitely a new
experience i-i-i think it's less moving
parts so less prone to failure and then
also I think in the future we want to
get away from any physical buttons where
it's just it's just a digital touch
almost yeah so I can actually we can see
that this is the LCD backing and then we
have the two wires I can actually remove
the camera and show you guys that camera
because you
asked about it so while AJ is doing this
just a reminder that this is AJ Forsyth
he is the founder and CEO I'm sorry the
co-founder and CEO of I cracked
yeah I'm Haley Joel Osment look-alike
Haley don't look alike but it's not I
promise if you have questions please
send this up please send them our way
I'm Jin Cal Tech reporter of Liberty's
okay so you are now removing the camera
we're breaking apart the new iPhone 7
yes and so I'm going to grab this little
screw that I just unscrewed okay that
was holding the camera that was holding
the camera and then I have a magnetic
mount right here and we can remove this
this is called the EMF shield and that
basically tries to prevent
electromagnetic interference from
interfering with the camera so we're
gonna pop that out so while you're doing
that the new battery that the iPhone 7
uses it is a lower powered battery than
the one that the new samsung note 7 uses
right so at the same time at 7 minutes
like it 330 500 mil amps per hour this
is a twenty-nine hundred milliamps per
hour you know your milliamp I do that
difference make make this battery less
dangerous like as an is this tone going
to set on fire that's actually a great
question no this is not set itself on
fire one of the one of the interesting
things is if you're if you open the
phone incorrectly you can puncture the
battery and the battery will actually it
can ignite and it's happened to our our
it's happened to myself personally it
was crazy like the phone catches on fire
but I mean Apple does such an amazing
job at their internal power supply units
that I don't think that this is a risk
at all like zero but you do want to be
very careful one of the one of the
reasons that we certify all of our high
Tech's we get around around 80 thousand
people a year apply to be in high tech
we end up saying not accepting 98% of
those that apply and we only take the
top 2% of technicians and apply through
our network and then they go through
about 20 hours of training so that so
that
they're professionals when they're
repairing your vices but we can take out
this little camera you can you can hold
it and see that how tiny it is for being
a 12 megapixel camera I think if you
remember a decade ago when digital
cameras are first came out how massive
they were now that's 12 megapixels in a
about the size of a dime with the same
quality as the digital cameras that
first came out so much canon much much
higher quality so I think the first
cameras that were commercially available
or 1.3 megapixels this is 12 megapixels
so about 10 times more powerful and
about a thousand times smaller which is
crazy but so I'm gonna remove the taptic
engine and this is what actually
vibrates your phone when you get a
notification or when you touch the home
button so all these manufacturers work
really hard to make sure that to do all
the testing to make sure that the
batteries aren't going to ignite on fire
even if it gets punctured like I believe
with a standard test is actually to
drive three nails during the testing
really through the batteries that's
right so you know and that's like that's
a pretty crazy test yeah yeah and the
problem I think is even if you have a
great design on the battery if you put
it into manufacturing something could
happen along the lines during that
process that could cause issues and
preserve the future so so you know going
back to this battery like I guess what
is the risk that something could be
wrong with the battery even if it's not
to catch on fire so if you think that
between all the smart phone
manufacturers they're gonna ship over
500 million devices this year the with
the amount of errors on that 500 million
number being as small as it is I don't I
don't think there are like any consumer
risks however if there has been a
manufacturing defect one in a million
even at even how small that sounds there
could still be 500 issues a year so that
when you're just dealing with large
numbers unfortunately like quality
control
can break down at some point in the in
the supply chain minimal risk for sure
so this is the taptic engine which is
the phone's vibrator and we can see that
it is actually screwed in right here and
the reason that we're taking this apart
is this is where the headphone jack was
so I want to show you guys what is what
is there now one of our viewers actually
has a really great question I'm going to
pose to you if Apple is all about this
Wireless future why is it that even with
this phone
we don't have Marla's charging section
amazing question I may be the technology
is not there I know that I would
certainly use that feature but a
wireless charging tends to it consumes a
lot of energy and it's wildly
inefficient from a power management
standpoint but it also you're never
going to be able to with current
technology you won't be able to charge
as fast as a lightning port with a
direct connection so I think that I mean
I'm certain it's probably on a bunch of
phone makers radar but it may have just
not have made sense given that every new
year they have to come out with a new
iteration but I would I don't maybe wait
till the ten-year anniversary next time
how fast does the iPhone charge with the
Lightning port versus a fast charging
phone of the other makers I don't have
that information I can make it up though
I'd say twice as fast I'm just kidding
I'm not I'm not sure but so this is we
can see that this is the taptic engine
and this is how it's held to the logic
board and I'm going to pull it out for
you what is the logic logic board so the
log if you think of the logic board is
the brains of your phone so the battery
is right here your SIM cards right here
and then the new Intel chip is under
this shielding and so if this is where
your memory which is all your like
photographs contacts everything is
stored on this right side of the device
oh it's amazing so it's actually one of
Intel's first forays on a chip designed
for for LTE on the iPhone and Intel's
just an amazing company so I would
expect that you're gonna have no issues
whatsoever but
because until previously it hasn't
really dominated a smartphone III would
a lot of people there's a lot of
speculation that they may have missed
the smartphone boat now that it looks
like they're on the on the boat now but
so if you hold this and you can feel how
heavy it is that actually makes up a
significant weight of the phone itself
and that's what replaced the headphone
jack internally so this is the when you
touch the home button
there's no click it vibrates this is
what causes that vibration I don't you
know I it's a it's it's incredibly well
designed internally then you have your
lightning port right here and then
here's the speaker which you can you can
see how big the speaker is that takes
it's about the size of a quarter and and
all of our I Tech's around the US can
replace just about any component
internally also there's a new component
to it to remind us what that new speaker
is so on the seven-plus there's actually
another speaker on the top of the phone
right here as well for like stereo sound
on the iphone 7 there actually is just
the single speaker down here but then
you have another microphone up here but
we're gonna start probably reassembling
this one and I can probably do that
fairly quick are there any other
questions
I believe it's 649 and 749 but don't
quote me on that how is the speaker
quality for this phone oh it's amazing
so it's supposed to be twice as loud for
a speaker phone then than the 6s so I
haven't had a chance to use it
but I am excited to do a lot of
conference calls with Bloomberg Cal from
Bloomberg I cover technology and this is
AJ Forsythe of I cracked and we are
breaking apart or we have broken apart
this iPhone 7 so please send us any
questions that you might have are there
any other viewer questions I actually
wanted to ask about this screen yes you
know I know that Corning has
been talking about their new gorilla
five glass it's a lot more durable it
does the iPhone use durable glass for an
iPhone repair company what is that what
does that mean well they're gonna play
out it seriously how what is what is
this new glass isn't any new how many
layers so the there's never been an
official announcement that this is
Gorilla Glass five it just means that a
more durable screen is on the on the
device however it's important to keep in
mind that one in four devices are gonna
break regardless so as techni if you
look at the technology curve over over
time things may get stronger and more
durable but things are getting thinner
and larger so as it with a larger
surface area you're gonna have more
torsion and it's you're just gonna
phones are still going to break for the
next couple of years as far as we can
see wasn't something that the keynote
had covered is that right yes so they
actually didn't cover it at all which I
which are whole company which is about a
hundred people when we were watching it
we were kind of cheering that were were
we have another year of fixing phones
it's not a surprise they talked about in
previous keynotes they have it we had we
had kind of known all the specs
beforehand and so we weren't we weren't
that shocked but is so we're not going
to dunk this phone in the water because
we don't know we are we are not gonna
dunk in the water but if you do dunk it
in water how long can you keep it in for
what's the order the exact place so you
should you literally should be able to
go in the shower with this and have your
phone be fine and the tests that we've
already done this morning we put it in a
pitcher of water for 45 minutes and it
came out and what it's perfectly fine
the screen was actually on the entire
time which was uh which is interesting
but you can't yeah I don't think you're
supposed to I don't think I should go
scuba diving right maybe not even
swimming really that would be a kind of
a cool feature though I bet there's
be quite a few underwater selfies in the
next couple weeks you should take one to
go in the pool I do not have an iPhone 7
so I think mine is a not quite
waterproof okay so the microphone you
had mentioned is a new microphone right
uh you know like that I'm not sure of I
can make that up as well no I have not
when we power this back on we can test
it though okay are there any viewer
other viewer questions yes I'm sure it's
not a surprise to you everyone's really
worried about the matter
um how good is this battery actually
compared to the six asommus six like
what so this you should this has about
an hour more of this has about an hour
more of battery life than the 6s and
then the and then I believe probably two
hours more than the six so it is you get
more more usability time which is
awesome okay and where what's the future
and batteries what are we looking at you
know that's actually a great question so
we we used to have a internal research
project where we wanted to see if we
could put a fuel cell inside a iPad so
that you could fill up your iPad with
hydrogen and it sounds crazy but it you
put a fuel cell in an iPad but it needs
to be an open system to let heat and
water vapor out so I think fuel cells
are out for the time being however
there's some pretty crazy technology in
the lithium lithium sulfur batteries so
they can they're actually twice as light
but last twice as long
right now we have lithium ion batteries
what is the difference between
lithium-ion look in silver um so it's
actually that's an interesting question
so it's basically the chemical makeup of
like the electrolyte solution inside the
battery and and I'm not a scientist so I
can I stopped at about there but the I
think in the future you're gonna have
fast charging wireless charging and and
when I say fast charging imagine if you
could get a full battery for two to
three minutes of charging there's
there's some pretty interesting work
with
supercapacitors so that that's a similar
similar fields and I just think it's
gonna be
imagine if you could fully charge your
phone in two minutes so you never have a
dead phone I have oh it's probably say
in the next five years why is the iPhone
getting bigger
why are phones in general getting bigger
it's bigger better well I think I think
that's just the march to replace the
desktop is this is your number one
personal computer so you're doing more
emails on it more snapchats is there a
limit to how big a phone I think no I
mean I if you imagine all the usability
testing that they've done you need to be
able to hold it in one hand and put it
in pocket so I I I think we're on the
limit but if you want a bigger phone get
to and tape them together if the iPhone
7 the same size as the 6s or is a little
bigger so iPhone 7 and 6s are the exact
same size okay and the plus and the plus
are the same size and what are the so
what is that compare to the Android
equivalent so I guess since we've been
talking about Samsung all so the s7 is
comparable to the seven plus and and 6s
plus so you really shouldn't know a
difference there you're on like four and
a half inch screens it went from like
three point nine to four and a half to
five point five s and then I think that
the smart phones top out at about seven
so if you here's the home button which
is your touch ID your fingerprint sensor
so that so so that actually goes through
there's a wire under here comes up and
then goes over and it goes under these
five screws there's three different LCD
connections and then that actually tells
the taptic engine to vibrate when you
when you click it and this metal barrier
that's where the actual glasses of
Industry yes so that is there's the LCD
then
digitizer than the glass and if you I
believe it's it's a single layer of
glass with an oleophobic coating which
is anti fingerprint smudging and and
then you have the digitizer and then
your force touch which is like when you
press it you can like feel it like
almost pressing into the screen and then
your LCD is under that and I believe
it's five five layers when we when we
manufacture this stuff have you
scratched tested it yet I have I have
not but apparently the jet-black one
scratches very easily Oh on the back on
the back okay okay and do you want to
scratch destroy this this beautiful film
I can so when you do scratch test you
just scratch the the bags and the
friends also so ed ER so we run our own
supply chain so there's actually a
scratch test where you you put the
screen an abrasive what's called a
tumbler and then you tumble it and
imagine like a bunch of like coins keys
and then it tumbles on the the screens
and we try to make sure it doesn't
scratch like we use the I mean that you
should never when you use I cracked
which we have just to reiterate we have
five thousand people in the u.s. called
ITEX that you press a button and they
come to you and repair your device on
demand which is like a cool service
they'll come to your home office school
wherever and we certify all of them to
do repairs on our behalf and then we
make sure that all the parts that they
use are OEM like quality screen so you
should never know that your device was
ever repaired because it should operate
like it's brand-new you can buff them
out actually we uh we that is not a
service we currently offer but if you
scratch your phone I will remove the
scratches for you is the same process
for the back and the front the different
process actually I said the back is is a
little bit more difficult so this is us
closing the the front of the LCD here's
the battery here's the logic board which
is the
you think of it as the brains here's
touch ID which is the home button going
through there and so you you close it
like a book and then you put these top
two there's two little internal clips
and so you you pull this out like that
and then put it in and it should you'll
hear it
start snapping shut and you can kind of
tell you like it's like a soft pop we'll
see if I I still have it it's turning on
and it's no longer waterproof so this I
haven't put it in a bucket of water but
I I would doubt that it is still
waterproof okay oh we should maybe not
but so this is uh this is turning on and
that that was your iPhone 7
I guess internal review most people have
never seen the inside of their phones
it's a remarkably complex machine took
along it took us five years to end up
training our I Tech's on how to do the
repairs but we're one of the largest
companies in the world that does that
right now the back is is this what is
the material so that is anodized series
what's called series 7000 aluminum which
is aircraft grade strength and the
anodization process so it starts out
silver if you think of like a coke cam
and then you dip it in a in a bath it's
actually Apple at their keynote had a
pretty interesting video on this you dip
it in bath to anodize it and it
basically builds a layer of of coating
on on that aluminum which is why you can
do the different colors rose gold white
or in this case that was so we know that
the iPhone pluses have sold out and
their giant quality Apple has warned
about that they said that they expected
all those seven and seven pluses phones
to sell out this weekend
did they it's awesome yeah but they good
thing we're in line this morning you
know what they didn't do though is
they're not telling us what the weekend
the initial weekend other sorry I think
I mean if their stock price as of late
is any reflection of their sales I think
they're doing
they should sell every now they said
should sell over 200 million funds this
year which is it is staggering when you
think about those numbers how much of
that you think it's gonna be the seven I
have no idea we'll have to ask our good
friend Benedict Evans who does quite a
bit of research on on the iPhone markets
what was the sentiment when you were
there how were the lines I know I mean
seven days crazy but how are the lines
in comparison to the launch of the six
the six oh my gosh they're like hundreds
of people were lined up it was it's like
when you were walking in it was like
walking into a rock concert with like
people cheering and having the time of
their life so it was it was a it was a
zoo
it was awesome that gives me a lot of
good so we've actually camped out for
the last four years the company i
crackes 5 years old we've camped out for
the last four of those five and now is
the place is packed I don't I don't know
how it compares good things I hope so
the more iPhones and Samsung but we do
quite a bit of Android repair as well
the more out there we see about one in
four break and so that's why we built a
company where you can press a button and
an eye crack technician will show up and
repair your device on-site it's like it
is the coolest service in my opinion our
eye techs are amazing thank you all
viewers I hope you enjoy this if you
like this video please like our Facebook
page and hope to see you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]